[Musique]
leur dire quoi au sujet des voyages
moi j'ai pas envie de froid sec tu me
donnes politiquement correct sera
évidemment évidemment l algérie alors
âgé vous coûter merakchi c'est
déplaisant à des pays a besoin d'aller
si loin fait un petit tour par barbes et
puis city flip comme on dit chez vous
c'est du second degré moi ça m'a fait
rire je ne supporte plus le
politiquement correct et suce boules un
jour suce boules toujours eu ce que je
voulais dire par des paysans c'est qu'on
n'ait pas envoyé par le tourisme de
masse comme en tunisie ou au maroc
ah oui mais nous quand on a visité la
cathédrale d'alger n'était tout seul
[Musique]
rien de tel que notre beau pays
pour apprécier la douceur de vivre tu te
sens pas stocker de bronze je revis on
est quand même très manga this de paris
corps moi j'ai du mal avec la france
mais avec odile on a décidé de
s'installer en israël
ç'a vraiment ont penché une opinion en
algérie par abonné à bombay de quel
rapport avec keira bolide le pays où les
gens se prosterne devant les vaches
c'est la solution
le gendre n'aime plus la france on va
leur faire aimer la france décidément
vos familles nous réserve toujours de
belles surprises
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore fait au bon
dieu claude jeu rien j'en sais rien on
va tout savoir à l'accouchement de leurs
brûlures n'accouche pas l'homme des
neiges passer après
si les noirs comme un sénégalais c'est
vrai qu'il est puis un petit diamant
le saosnois et plus fort c'est la
puissance africaine
et très très noir quand même alors ça me
dérange pas parce que je suis moi même
si ça manque de l'oreille très blonde et
je pensais que tu es bon tu as enfin
c'est juste un constat chérissez et on
en a encore le droit constaté d'un pays
je constate